you know what it never was
that's serious it was never that serious
stranger things Star Noah schnapp has
come out as gay in a new tick tock and
fans of the hit series are over the moon
for the actor schnapp revealed his
sexuality in The Cheeky video with the
caption I guess I'm more similar to will
than I thought which of course is a
reference to a stranger things character
will Byers who the show revealed in the
fourth season is queer based on his
romantic feelings towards Mike
[Music]
feel like she's not a mistake at all
[Music]
and when asked about the similarities
between him and his character will
during The Stranger Things season 4
premiere in May 2022 Noah had this to
say well is just very scared of
everything of the world and stuff I'm
pretty brave and outgoing yeah you are
okay now the actor did catch up with
variety back in July 2022 and when asked
about his characters coming out journey
he stated now that he's gotten older
they made it a very real obvious thing
now it's 100 clear that he is gay and he
does love Mike but before it was a slow
Arc I think it is done so beautifully
because it is so easy to make a
character just like all of a sudden be
gay but when it came to his own coming
out experience the 18 year old actor
wrote to his fans explaining that what I
finally told my friends and family I was
gay after being scared in the closet for
18 years and all they said was we know
quite frankly we'll never be that
serious
hey thanks for watching ET Canada if you
want more queer entertainment news and
exclusive interviews be sure to
subscribe and check out